This is Just Happening Now breaking news
Twitter temporarily closes office
building suspends employee access on
Thursday it was revealed that Twitter
had temporarily closed its Office
Buildings and suspended access badges
the officers offices are expected to
reopen Monday November 21st giving Elon
Musk and his team a chance to sort
things out sort what out
no details as given why they just
basically shut down we're hearing this
is because Elon Musk and his team are
terrified employees are going to
sabotage the company also they're still
trying to figure out which Twitter
workers they need to cut access for
shift report that employees were being
told to continue to comply with company
policy by refraining from discussing
confidential company information on
social media with the press or elsewhere
it's interesting Elon Musk effectively
performed a hostile takeover of a woke
institution yes these these people are
whiny baby children and are imploding
and this is what happens when you do